valerie's with us
in butte montana hi valerie welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call
great so my question is about
asking for a recommendation about going
taking out a loan um taking out a couple
loans currently i don't have
any debt i own an
older vehicle and i just started nursing
school
so i'm going to have to take out some
loans to complete school
and i'm going to need to take out a loan
to
get a vehicle that will be sustainable
in
montana weather for the winter
um so my my question is what is your
record what did you do last winter
oh i had i had the same vehicle that i
have now
in montana in montana you made it
yes okay keep the vehicle
yeah yeah okay all right
problem one solved listen you don't go
into debt to buy a car because you think
it's gonna snow in montana
we already knew it was gonna snow in
montana
it snowed last year in montana and you
made it last year
okay so you're going to limp through
you're a broke college student you don't
go in debt buying cars
please darling please don't do that okay
how much is nursing school costing you
um for so i have two and a half years
left two and a half years so i have
about 15 000.
oh that's wonderful you can get find
15 000 and finish nursing school debt
free
awesome well i don't i don't have the 15
000
no we've just got to go get it right
that's
awesome you didn't tell me 150 000 that
would have been harder
oh that's so good are you living at home
feels like a lock i know it feels like i
do oh that's awesome so you don't have
overhead
mom and dad are feeding you and putting
you up while you're going to nursing
school by the way i'm happy you're going
to nursing school
if you haven't heard i'm a big fan of
nursing school i think it's a great
career
so how old are you thank you well i'm
i'm a non-traditional student i'm
i'm 27. okay so i'm i'm back
i'm back at home gotcha okay and um
so uh you have a year and a half of
nursing school left
i i have i'm sorry i have i have two two
and a half years
and fifteen thousand dollars covers that
yes in two and a half years so
seven thousand eight thousand dollars a
year so
what i'm what i'm calculating from is i
i do have some grant money that i
could have secured before school so good
good
but here's the thing here's the thing
you do not go to nursing school on
saturday and sunday
and you do not go to nursing school at
on thursday night do you
that's true this is when you're working
and this is where you get eight hundred
to a thousand dollars a month
by the way a thousand dollars a month is
twelve thousand dollars a year
over two years that's twenty four
thousand dollars you only need fifteen
okay you need a thousand dollar a month
income
no overhead at home make the car make it
through
work your little tail end off and come
out of school with absolutely no debt
the 20 set the the uh the 30 year old
version of you
will love the hard-working hard-nosed
tough montana girl that's 27.
but if you wuss out and go buy a car on
payments
and you wish out and go run up twenty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
the 30 year old version of you is going
to come back and kick your little wussy
butt
okay am i right yes
and not all that makes makes perfect
sense yeah
what's hard because i think i'm i'm
planning on my car failing i think
that's where my fear comes in of how am
i going to
i plan on all my cars failing they all
suck
all of them break so what are you
driving how many miles this thing got on
it um it's a 2004
taurus and it has 101 000 miles
oh definitely a piece of garbage yeah
definitely a hooptie
okay so that's worth what 1500 bucks
maybe yeah yeah okay so we may want to
add another thousand dollars of extra
work somewhere and come up with another
thousand dollars and you know get a 2500
car instead of a 1500
car but with cash of course
okay your dad does stuff like i'm
talking about doesn't he
yes yeah yeah okay you can do this
it's hard now but easier later easy now
is really hard later
you get to choose which place you do the
hard do it now
this is the dave ramsey show